ces photos ont été publiées sur le
compte télégramme du maire de
melithopole elle témoigne selon lui de
l'évacuation des habitants des zones
proches de la centrale de zapporigia
sous occupation russe des évacuations
qui interviennent alors que les
bombardements auraient redoublé dans la
région et après que le chef de l'agence
internationale pour l'énergie atomique a
mis en garde contre le risque d'un grave
accident nucléaire
la situation dans la zone proche de la
centrale nucléaire de zapporisia devient
de plus en plus imprévisible et
potentiellement dangereuse cette grande
installation nucléaire doit être
protégée la ioa continuera à faire tout
ce qui est en son pouvoir pour
contribuer à garantir la sûreté la
sécurité nucléaire de la centrale Rafael
grossit assure que des experts de
l'Agence se trouvent dans la zone pour
surveiller la situation de la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'Europe
centrale dont les forces russes se sont
emparés peu après le début de l'invasion
de l'Ukraine en février 2022 c'est
notamment dans cette région cruciale
contrôlée à 80% par Moscou qui a tendu
la contre-offensive ukrainienne en mars
le chef de l'IA s'était rendu sur place
pour trouver des mesures de protection
de la zone acceptable pour Moscou et
pour keV